[Applause]
so good to be back here you guys I'm
having a huge week I just became an
uncle for the first time which is really
great thank you so much I had nothing to
do with it so it's pretty cool it still
feels good to be congratulated though I
like that a lot I like being an uncle
it's very cool less cool I come from a
very religious family and there are a
lot of people in my family who are
concerned about me being around the baby
because I'm gay and which is so
offensive to me because I can do so much
better than some stupid baby ok get one
thing straight look at me alright that
baby wishes ok my beautiful niece could
do so well alright I see what they're
saying now she was like a wild time to
bring a child into the world lots going
on the Nazis are back people are wearing
corduroy Nazis are wearing corduroy you
know just like lots in the air I feel
like in the last couple of years a lot
of people were like oh we have a black
president we did it we solved racism and
now this entire period of history we're
currently living through is like the end
of a horror movie when you think the
killer is dead and then a hand reaches
out of the grave and grabs and is like
gotcha [ __ ] this is a franchise
[Applause]
racism in space yet you know it's never
going to end ever with all that in mind
I've been trying to be kind to everyone
really connect with everyone I meet
which is a mistake it's bad I was in a
cab recently and the driver is playing a
Spanish speaking radio station and I
said this is my chance I'm gonna connect
with him over this and I said sir you
have to tell me what is the song that's
playing on the radio right now it's so
beautiful I have to know and he flipped
around looked me dead in the face and
was like it's an Oreo commercial that is
humiliated just open the door flung
myself out and I'm dead where I find
myself now I love this job it's a great
job I get to fly a lot which is a big
part because I love planes I just flew
back Seattle to New York and on that
plane every single member of the flight
crew every flight attendant was male and
I was like where the hell am i Spain you
know he's so stupid and to make matters
worse the flight attendant that was
helping arroz he was a male flight
attendant who was both straight and rude
and I was like oh you can't do that if
you're gonna be a male flight attendant
you could either be gay and rude or
straight and good at your job you know
that you can't have every option
available to you it's just not fair
yeah I feel like you guys should be glad
that we allow you in the skies at all
you know because everybody knows that
the skies were given to gay men and
straight women centuries ago when we
were tricked out of the land lesbians of
course we're given the Seas bisexual men
are pilots and bisexual women are
captain's you know that's just history
okay read a book I like reading law
I like being gay I think it's great I
think I'm crashing and I recommend it to
everybody I need not everybody thinks
I'm doing such a great job there are a
lot of gay men who don't think I'm a
very good role model for the community I
had one come up to me after a show in
Phoenix recently and he got in my face
and was like you're everything that's
wrong with the gay community it's gay
men like you you're the reason my
parents don't talk to me and I was like
oh my god I'm so sorry but you're the
only gay person your parents know so
this feels like it's a you thing
I bet if your parents met me they'd be
jazzed you know so excited like oh my
god we didn't know they could be cool I
thought they were all lame virgins like
her son but whew what a relief you know
a little update about me since the last
time I was here I'm still alone it's
rough I think dating is really hard for
me as I push three because I just don't
have any room left in my brain for facts
about other people I just don't care I
went on a first date with a guy recently
who told me that he was born in London
but was raised in Tampa and isn't that
the saddest story you've ever heard
everything you're gonna have the best
accent imaginable instead you've got HPV
from the ocean you know like what
happened there that's like our
generations version of for sale baby
shoes never worn you know like this
tells a whole story in one sentence
alright you guys have been fantastic
[Applause]
you